hi everybody welcome to game life as you
can see today we're down to Capcom's
office in San Mateo California for their
first annual digital day now digital
distribution are buying video games
online on services like Xbox Live Arcade
as opposed to buying them in a store is
becoming big business for a lot of video
game publishers right now and perhaps
none more so than Capcom who are putting
a whole lot of energy into a lineup of
digital download titles for this year
they're making the multi-platform you're
going to be able to buy all these games
on either xbox or playstation 3 and in
some cases the pc and they're using
digital distribution to bring back a lot
of their classic franchises like 1942
commando bionic commando and yes Street
Fighter 2 so they've got all these
titles in their office right now ready
for us to go and play so come on with me
let's check them out and talk to some of
the developers
blender is a action RTS it's a very
accessible election RTS which is pretty
unusual it's for PlayStation Network
xbox live arcade and windows actually a
simultaneous release but it's a pirate
games that you avila pirate ship and you
and your teammate sail around capturing
towns gathering resources and trying to
meet the game objective which is always
available in controlling a certain
number of towns but it's a very very
easy game to pick up and play but it's
got a lot of depth a lot of complexity
under the surface a lot of strategic
complex data it goes into it just like
any good board game we kind of wanted to
do a small game who were a brand new
company we've been on for a little bit
we did a map pack for Halo 2 and when we
started looking at getting into full
product development we're working
towards much bigger goals much you know
bigger more ambitious things but at the
same time one of the things that I've
learned over the years is that it's
really dangerous to grow too quickly
both in terms of the size of your team
and to relax your hiring standards and
these sorts of things and just to be
able to put a new team together in new
studio and to get the right process in
place and are in people you want to grow
at a kind of measured pace so a smaller
game which no happens in this case be
downloadable delivery really allows us
to do a full feature development cycle
but on a sort of a smaller game I think
we actually started on this a year ago
to the day what I used to do it's funny
it's not that different than what I do
now to stun a different product but I
was the online multiplayer lead for the
Halo games halo 2 and 3 before that I
did the user interface for halo 1 and
was with bungee for about 10 years prior
to founding certain affinity and my
focus has always been on
the funds or cooperative multiplayer
server online experiences so what I do
now is pretty similar to what I did then
but with a much smaller budget so about
a year ago Capcom came to us and they
had this kind of new thought and where
they wanted to go with the games and the
biggest thing they want to push for was
digital distribution which was kind of
ironic because internally we had decided
we would kind of move the whole company
into digital speech and I think a lot of
people were starting to wonder if that's
where the future is going to be and
we're kind of picking apart my
distribution meant so we signed up a
number of games we announced the fighter
two turbo HD remix and then we also have
commando in 1942 coming up so we just
announced finally that those who buy
commando three are going to be invited
to an exclusive beta of super street
fighter two turbo HD remix and that's
going to be an eight-week trial where
people get to try to break the
networking go in there just maximize the
system because what we want to do is
when Street Fighter comes out it's got
to be perfect everybody demands
perfection so the best way to do that is
get that out there in the hands of
gamers and have them just bang away and
we're unlocking a lot of the major modes
from tournament to quarter match and
restrict lon one and just trying to get
the metrics of a play and make sure that
this thing's going to be ready for
launch when it goes it's gonna be
perfect so what is this game is actually
two games in one and both of these games
are based on the game called Super Turbo
from 14 years ago and it's that's
basically the classic one of the most
cherished versions of Street Fighter and
where we're doing it but you get two
games so one of them has the gameplay
exactly the same as the original arcade
and we've gone to great lengths to make
it exactly the same as the original and
then the other game you get the HD remix
game has all new rebalanced gameplay
where we've kind of learned the lessons
of tournaments over the last 14 years
and we've tried to improve the balance
but regardless of which one you play
either one there are there's this whole
host of changes so that the art is the
major one every single piece of art and
the entire game has been redrawn or
reimagined in 1080p and when people hear
that if they think the characters of
course the characters are in 1080p and
the backgrounds but it's not just that
it's ever
piece of art it's the win icons the
timer the HUD but you know but the
transitions between screens so there's
there's this thousands and thousands of
pieces of heart that we've drawn another
thing is the music and the there's 16
stages in this game like a arenas you
fight in and each one has its own music
each one has its own fast and slow
version is at the end of the round it
plays more quickly especially 32 tracks
and we've had all of them redone by the
community at OC remix so that it's
really interesting that the community
has directly contributed to the game in
that way all the endings when you when
you beat the computer that endings have
been redrawn by who don and we and
rewritten even to clean up the story
line a little bit and of course the game
is online so big jump from the arcade
days so new art online you music and new
gameplay if you want it or classic
gameplay if you don't
you